We've seen previously that
if a rope is under tension
and we approximate
the rope is massless
that the tension is then uniform
everywhere along the rope,
even if the rope is accelerated.
However, if the rope
has nonzero mass,
then its tension will
vary along its length.
We can see that by
looking at this example.
Imagine we have a massive
rope of length l suspended
from a ceiling.
Now, it's easy to see that,
at the top of the rope,
a little element of
rope right at the top
has to support the entire
weight of the entire rope.
So if I were to examine just a
little piece at the top here,
the weight of the entire rope
would be acting downwards.
And for the rope to
remain stationary,
there has to be
a tension upward.
I'll call this t-top, because
this is at the top of the rope.
And so we see
immediately from that
that at the top of
the rope, the tension
is just equal to mg, where m
is the mass of the entire rope.
Similarly, if we asked
what the tension is
at the bottom of the
rope, an element right
at the bottom of the rope
isn't supporting any weight,
because there is
no weight below it.
And so at the
bottom, the tension
is 0, because there
is no weight pulling
on the bottom of the rope.
So the tension is going to vary
from mg at the top down to 0
at the bottom.
And if we wanted to work
out at some distance
from the ceiling--
let's call it x--
at some position x-- say
here, what the tension is
at that point-- one way of
figuring that out would just
be imagine we cut the
rope at this point
and then asked
what tension force
would be necessary to support
this bottom part of the rope.
This length is l
minus x, so the mass
of that fraction of the
rope is l minus x over l.
And the mass of that
fraction of the rope
is that fraction times m.
And so the tension at
this point, t at x,
is equal to the weight
of the length of rope
below that point.
So that's this mass times g.
And I can rewrite that as
1 minus x over l times mg.
And this gives me mg
if I put in x equals 0,
and it gives me 0 if
I put in x equals l.
So that's one way of
figuring this out.
I'd like to use this
same example, though,
to introduce another, more
elegant way of analyzing
what the tension as a function
of a position on this rope.
The advantage-- so this is
going to be a little bit more
complicated, but it's a
much more powerful method,
and it's one that
we can generally
use for any continuous
distribution of mass as opposed
to a point mass.
So let's consider the same
example again of a hanging mass
of rope of length l and mass m.
Here's the length
l and the mass m.
And the approach
we're going to use
is called differential analysis.
It's a technique from
calculus, and it's
applicable to any continuous
distribution of mass.
What we're going
to do is imagine
our continuous
distribution of mass
is made up of a whole bunch of
little pieces, little elements,
examine f equals ma acting
on a single element,
and then generalize
to the entire mass.
So let's do that here.
What we'll do is we'll examine
a piece at some position x.
So I'm measuring x from the top.
And let's say I define
a little element here,
which is that of position x and
which has an extent delta x.
So this thickness is
delta x, and we'll
call the mass of that little
piece, that little element,
delta m.
Now, one thing I want to
point out to begin with
is that we want to pick an
element that's somewhere
in the middle of
the distribution,
not at one end or the other.
The endpoints are
special cases, so we
want to pick a general case.
So choose some x somewhere in
the middle of our distribution
which has a finite extent.
That extent is delta x.
In this case, we'll assume
that that piece delta x
has a mass delta m.
So let's blow that up
here and analyze it.
So here is my element.
And it's going to have--
let's analyze what
the forces acting on it are.
So there's gravity
acting downwards,
which will be delta m times g.
There is a tension
acting upwards,
exerted by the rope above it.
I'll write that as t of x,
because it's at the location x.
There's also a tension exerted
in the downward direction
by the remainder of the
rope below the mass element.
And I'll call that
t of x plus delta x.
We expect the tension
to vary along the rope.
And because this element
does have a finite extent,
the tension at the
bottom is going
to be slightly different
than the tension at the top-
so t of x upwards, t of
x plus delta x downwards,
and then the weight downwards.
So let's now-- that's
our free body diagram.
Let's write down
Newton's second law,
f equals ma for
that mass element.
So in the positive
direction, which is downward,
we have t of x plus
delta x plus delta mg.
And then in the upward
or minus direction,
we have minus t of x.
So those are the
combined forces.
Now, this rope is suspended.
It's not moving.
And so mass object
acceleration is just 0.
I'm going to rearrange that.
I can write that as t of x
plus delta x minus t of x
is equal to minus
delta m times g.
And by the way,
let me remind you--
if this were a massless rope,
then delta n would be 0.
And so the right-hand
side would be 0,
and the tension
would be uniform.
We'd have the same
tension above and below.
But because the
rope does have mass,
and in particular, this element
has a nonzero mass delta m,
there is a difference
in the tensions.
OK.
Now, our delta m can
be represented in terms
of what this length is.
Notice that that mass, delta
m-- so note that delta m
is just a fraction
of the total mass
that's in that
particular mass element.
Well, the fraction
of the total rope
is just the length of
this element, delta x,
divided by the length of
the entire rope, which is l.
So that's the fraction,
and I multiply that
by the total mass.
So that is my mass delta
m in terms of the length.
So now I can rewrite
this equation
as t of x plus
delta x minus t of x
is equal to minus delta
x m over l times g.
Now, I'm going to
rearrange this by dividing
both sides by delta x.
I'll do that over here.
So we have t of x
plus delta x minus t
of x divided by delta x is
equal to minus mg over l.
This tells us how the
tension is varying
over this small but finite-sized
mass element, delta x.
Now I'd like to
examine what happens
if I go to the limit of
a small-massed element--
the limit as delta x goes
to 0, or in other words,
the limit of an infinitesimally
small mass element.
So I'm going to take the
limit of this equation
as delta x approaches 0.
Now, the left-hand side of this
equation should look familiar.
It's just an expression for
the derivative of the tension
t as a function of position.
So I can write that
as dt dx, and that's
equal to minus mg over l.
This is an example of a
differential equation,
or an equation that
involves a derivative.
This particular
differential equation
can be solved very simply
by a technique called
the separation of
variables, where I just
take each part of the
integral-- the dt and the dx--
and put it on different
sides of the equation
and then integrate both
to find the solution.
So in this case, I'll multiply
both sides of the equation
by dx.
So I get dt on
the left-hand side
is equal to minus mg over l dx.
And now I want to
integrate both sides.
So I'll integrate this side.
And remember, mg
over l is a constant,
so I can keep it
outside the integral.
And I'll integrate this side.
I'm going to do a
definite integral
over the continuous
distribution that I'm studying.
So on the right-hand side, I'm
going to start at x equals 0
and go to my position
of interest, which is x.
And to avoid
confusion, I'm going
to call the integration
viable dx prime.
This is a dummy variable.
So x prime here represents
all the values of position,
ranging from my first endpoint
0 up to my other endpoint x.
So x here represents
a particular position,
whereas dx prime
is a placeholder
for all the positions
between the two
endpoints in my infinite
sum, which is an integral.
So that's on the
right-hand side.
On the left-hand side, I'm
integrating the tension t,
with respect to the tension t.
My limits need to
correspond to the limits
on the right-hand side integral.
So on the right-hand side, my
lower limit is at x equals 0.
So on the left-hand
side, I want to have
my lower limit be the tension
at that position x equals 0.
So that's t of 0.
And then the upper
limit of the integral
is the tension at the upper
limit of the position integral,
so that's t of x.
And again, to avoid
confusion, I'm
actually going to call the
integration variable dt prime.
This is a dummy variable.
It's a placeholder
for all the values
of tension from the
tension at x equals 0
to the tension at my
position of interest x.
And so this integral
now tells me
how the tension is varying
in a continuous fashion
along this continuous
mass distribution.
So now I can evaluate
both integrals.
On this side, I
have the integral
of a constant with
respect to the tension.
And so that's just going to
give me t of x minus t of 0,
and that's equal
to minus mg over l.
The interval of dx prime
from 0 to x is just x.
So this tells me how the tension
changes from the endpoint
to some arbitrary position x.
If I want to actually
solve for t of x,
I need to specify what the
tension is at the endpoint.
But we know what the
We found that earlier.
We solved from the simple
argument that at the endpoint,
the tension here is
just equal to the weight
of the entire length of
rope below that point.
So we know that t at x
equals 0 is just equal to mg.
And therefore, the
tension at position
x is just-- if I bring
[INAUDIBLE] of 0 to this side
is just mg minus mg x over l.
And so I can just write that
as mg times 1 minus x over l.
So that tells me
what the tension
is as a function of position.
Note again that if I put in
x equals 0, I just get mg.
If I put in x equals l,
I get the tension is 0.
And for any point in between,
we see that the tension varies
smoothly between mg and 0.
This is exactly the same
result we found earlier
by just cutting the
rope at x and asking
how do we balance the
weight of the remaining
rope below that point.
But the advantage
of this technique
which is a little
bit more complicated,
is that it's a very
powerful technique
applicable to any continuous
distribution of mass.
So in this specific problem, if
instead of the uniform density
rope that we had here, imagine
we had a clumpy rope where
the mass of the rope wasn't
distributed smoothly,
but there were clumps,
little parts of the rope that
were heavier than others,
and so the density varied
with position along the rope.
In that case, we would
represent that when
we were writing what our
mass element delta m is.
Delta m, instead of just
being delta x over l times m,
where here, delta x over
l was the uniform density
of the rope, we
would have to put
in some position-dependent
density.
So delta n would
depend upon position.
And then when I did this
integral, instead of
a constant out front with
my integral of dx prime,
I would have some thing
that was a function of x,
and I'd get a different
value for the integral.
But the technique
would still work.
So this differential
analysis technique
is applicable to any system
where we have a continuous mass
distribution.
And we're going to actually use
this technique over and over
again in this course.
We'll see it a number of times.
This is just the first
instance we're using it.
We wanted to introduce you
carefully to the approach.